in the last couple of weeks you have
probably heard me used the term
management by optics and I've used this
term to refer to the handling of
coronavirus by Donald Trump and the
administration and I've also applied it
to Mike Pence and Donald Trump's non use
of masks during recent public
appearances and there's now a new report
from The Associated Press excellent
article which says that indeed according
to people close to Trump not authorised
to speak about this Trump is refusing to
wear a mask in public because number one
he believes he would look ridiculous
wearing one and number two and this is
the more interesting piece he believes
it'll hurt his chances at being
reelected because of the message that
wearing a mask would send and we'll get
to that report in a second so one
example of management by optics is the
case numbers and the death numbers are a
disaster we've been in these sort of
rolling patch works of stay at home
orders now for close to two months and
the numbers are terrible every day we're
finding around 25,000 new cases of
corona virus despite testing not having
increased that dramatically or much at
all over the last half month or so we
had it spikes once again this week to
2,500 deaths on multiple days during the
week so the way that Trump is managing
by optics is simply not talking about
deaths and cases manage the optics which
are saved that we won talk about these
heroic warriors which are the Americans
Trump is talking about talk about how we
are now getting to reopen the economy in
30 states or whatever the number they
claim is are starting to reopen their
state economies Mike Pence didn't wear a
mask when he went to the Mayo Clinic
recently and he was excoriated for it
ended up wearing a mask
on his next visit out but again it's the
optics of if you say things are going
really well if you say we're past the
peak if you say we've won if you say we
are now in the recovery mode you
certainly can't be seen wearing a mask
for the first time in public that would
imply things are not as good as you
claim they are so that gets us to Donald
Trump earlier this week Donald
flew out to Arizona we covered it
covered some of his live events there he
went literally to a mask factory a
factory repurposed facility of Honeywell
where they are making masks and they
have in you know right on the wall on a
TV it's as mandatory masks keep a mask
on at all times
Trump didn't wear a mask and one is once
again we knew we suspected based on what
we know about Trump that this is more
management by optics Trump wearing a
mask when he says we've basically won
were past it were reopening it's all
great he succeeded at keeping the death
toll well below two million it doesn't
send the right signal and indeed that's
exactly what the new report says Trump
believes that if he was seen wearing a
mask
it would hurt his chances of re-election
it would make him look ridiculous Trump
has had two advisers that wearing a mask
would quote send the wrong message and
it would make him seem preoccupied with
health I for me it would be good I would
love to see Trump preoccupied with
health that's the problem the problem is
he seems not to care about health Trump
also has told confidants according to
the same Associated Press report that he
fears he would look ridiculous in a mask
and that the image of him wearing a mask
would be used in negative ads against
him understand the insanity of that the
mask has become a proxy political
statement at this point in time if you
wear a mask it means you believe this is
serious you believe things are bad you
believe people should be scared not
wearing a mask means you don't trust
these hoaxes or governor's or
everything's fine or the economy will
soon be open and people will soon or
have already stopped dying from
coronavirus it's now a political
statement something that is just
supposed to be a matter of science just
to be supposed to be a matter of Health
the masks are worn for very empirical
demonstrable reasons now they have
become political calculations and I hate
to tell you maybe Trump is making the
right calculation for his followers
seeing Trump wear a mask to somebody
like me
would say Trump understands the science
Trump trusts the experts Trump cares
about other people but Trump is the guy
who looked directly at a solar eclipse
and he's making the equivalent choice
here with the masks now I I have to tell
you the looking ridiculous thing this is
not a show that focuses on things like
the physical appearance of our elected
officials but Trump's saying the mask
will make me look ridiculous Trump has
been going around with a lunatic looking
fake tan for years he walks around in
these oversized suits very often even if
we grant the concern about looking
ridiculous with the mask and how that
might affect his supporters or whatever
Trump regularly looks ridiculous and so
that is also sort of a complicated thing
to get a sense of but it's not the most
important thing the most important thing
here is the continued management by
optics and the really sad reality that
when it comes to his followers he may be
right his followers may see him wearing
a mask and actually be turned off by it
and unfortunately when Trump's followers
see him not wearing a mask it encourages
them not to wear one which leads to
viral spread which leads the cases which
leads to deaths it's very very ugly
management by optics extraordinarily
dangerous and we're seeing that in
action look at the case numbers in these
states look at what's happening in Texas
look at what's happening in Georgia
Arizona states that are reopening early
it's not good and it's getting worse and
now Donald Trump is proactively saying
now I'm not going to be seen with a mask
that'll be used in ads there is news
that is pushing the virus closer to
Donald Trump himself the president has a
bunch of what are called the valets
there's sort of like personal assistants
in a lot of ways and these are some of
the closest people to presidents of the
United States they're often from the US
Navy they deal with food drink when
Trump is at the residence when Trump is
traveling they cater to the needs of the
first family in many cases these are
people that are really close to the
president physically and often they are
they are close in a relationship sense
well one of Donald Trump's personal
valets has tested positive for
coronavirus the valet started having
symptoms Wednesday morning tested
positive and Donald Trump was notified
about this we know that the virus can
take 2 to 14 days from infection to
symptoms it's an average of 5 days
before you show symptoms and presumably
this is a valet that has continued to be
in close contact with Donald Trump the
White House has not said that the valet
was not around Donald Trump so based on
how this administration works we
probably can assume that the valet was
around Donald Trump during this time the
White House continues not to enforce
social distancing for staffers reports
are that very few people at the White
House are wearing masks valets are not
wearing masks the physical distance is
not being adhered to very strictly at
the White House now here's my question
for you and I really want to think this
through
if Trump but Trump was tested right away
when the valet tested positive Trump was
tested once again if Trump tested
positive for coronavirus but he didn't
immediately need to go to a hospital for
example would they admit it would they
say that the president has tested
positive there's a North Korea like
Geist to this administration where I
don't know that they would admit that
the great orange leader in this case has
tested positive I also and this is a
different story but I also would not put
it outside the realm of possibility that
Trump and pence have been
prophylactically receiving antibody
transfusions the convalescent plasma
you're talking about the president and
the vice president it wouldn't be crazy
it's not even like oh my god their
receipt it would actually just seem
almost like that seems relatively safe
and it seems to be effective at treating
or dealing with the virus when people
have it it wouldn't be completely out of
this world to think maybe Trump and
pence have been getting prophylactic
transfusions but the real story is has
Donald Trump been exposed what are the
results of Donald Trump's tests has he
been taking chloric
prophylactically as he advocated for a
while might my guess is the answer is no
and right away when this news was
released about the valet testing
positive rumors started spreading that
Trump went silent on Twitter yesterday
because he had the virus I don't think
so he didn't tweet much for part of the
day then he was right back on Twitter
tweeting very very aggressively the most
important thing is to follow up about
once again we talked about it earlier
management bioptics Trump is not wearing
a mask because he says it'll make him
look ridiculous
he may be hurt in his reelection
campaign if he is seen wearing a mask
same thing applies to this if it became
known that Donald Trump had coronavirus
would his followers change their minds
about Donald Trump being this big strong
trustworthy guy I actually think it
might be a positive thing in the sense
of I'm not saying I want Trump to get
the virus but I do believe that some of
the people that followed Trump who loved
Trump who see him as a demigod if they
found out that Trump had coronavirus
they might start wearing masks they
might start adhering to social
distancing guidelines they might
actually start taking this more
seriously but in terms of would the
Trump administration admit that Trump
has the virus if it didn't require him
going to the hospital I don't know
I don't know I'm curious to see what you
think we have a fantastic program for
you today
remember you can sign up for the all-new
David Pakman show newsletter on our
website david pakman.com it will soon be
morphed into a print digest
version of the David Pakman show coming
up in the next couple of weeks it's free
it's free sign up at david pakman.com
also let me know what you think about
this prompt coronavirus testing thing
would they admit from has the virus if
it didn't require him to go to the
hospital
let me know on Twitter I am deep Ackman
deep
on twitter the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com welcome
back to the show today's new members of
the day are Orion
Aaron's and Shane troller Orion and
Shane thank you for your support also a
big THANK YOU to Charles parmesan II who
has been a member for almost five years
and is today's longtime sustaining
member of the day it's been a while
Charles I really appreciate that support
let's go to the phones and see if our
phone system is functioning at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let me go first to our caller
from the 6-5 one area code who is
calling today from 6 5 1 hi David it's
me yes it is hi this is Mike from the
Twin Cities Minnesota a big fan of your
show so my question to you today is um
as I'm sure you've heard there's
recently there's been like some
conservative infighting going on between
the traditional branches of conservatism
like ben shapiro charlie kurt and a more
like right-wing nationalistic form of
conservatism basically neo-nazis uh
mostly led by a guy named Nick Montes
right and I and a lot of people on the
Left are saying like all look like it's
funny like look there's this infighting
no unity among the right but I'm a
little worried about it because from my
perspective it doesn't seem like it's
just harmless infighting it seems like
the right is actually consolidating
behind Nick Fuentes and he's siphoning
off support from traditional
conservatism let me ask you a question
you've got let me ask you a question
what yeah
percentage of this country do you
believe knows who Nick Fuentes is oh
well right now not that high but when
you go online he's a very very popular
courier right I think here's my view on
this I think this is not a perfect
analogy by any means but in the same way
that if you just pay attention to
Twitter and reddit you probably had the
impression during the Democratic primary
that Bernie's support was dramatically
higher than what it really ended up
being in the primary a lot of the
slivers of the right are essentially
unknown in popular culture outside of
certain enclaves and in fact there are
tons of people in my audience who are
involved in the online political space
who also have no idea who Nick Fuentes
is I mean I know who he is but I don't
follow him in any way so I understand
the concern and there's no doubt that if
support on the right starts to
consolidate around movements like that
it would be a very very scary thing
right now I don't think it's going on
now that doesn't mean it won't happen
and that doesn't mean we don't need to
be worried about it but I think that we
really don't want to overstate the power
of these movements when when it doesn't
deserve to be overstated
that's a good point but I guess my
bigger question was what can the left
strategy be because what I've noticed is
that a lot of these people you know are
anti-capitalist and they advocate for a
lot of the same positions that we on the
left for free college free talent health
care but only for white people like
Nick's one says himself so on and we've
seen that in Europe - so how does the
Left respond to that well so so one
thing is I don't know that the left has
to respond to fights that right now are
mostly within the right I actually think
it's smarter for the left to stay out of
it completely and let them destroy
themselves or weaken themselves to the
extent that they will if at a certain
point though it goes more mainstream
which i think is what your concern is
then the left will have to put together
a strategy now if you check out my clip
from earlier this week populism may be
destroying social democracy I think part
of it is the left shouldn't get pulled
to exclusively populist rhetoric which
can be repurposed as you're pointing out
by bad actors like for example free
college for everyone except as long as
you're white we want to stick with the
policy based approach of social
democracy but but that's gonna be a
bigger question for the future all right
okay well thank you for taking my call
David appreciate the call great to hear
from you let's go next to let's go next
to Tim from the 631 it's been a few
months since I heard from argumentative
Tim as we have him in our call system
what's going on - oh that's my nickname
hon David yeah oh good to hear from you
I've been following you for quite some
time I saw a lot of people quite some
time and I wanted to get your take on
you know the current status of the
rollout of opening businesses and what
your take is on the Dallas woman that
recently got arrested and sent to jail
for opening her business while there at
the same time letting criminals out on
the street I think it's very
counterproductive I don't know anything
about that story in Dallas I just have
not seen it or read about it but I'll
check it out
I mean here's my datum my sense is that
there are states that have numbers that
justify safe socially distancing
reopening of some elements of the
economy we're starting to see the
numbers improve in a bunch of different
states and I want the economy reopened
as quickly as is safely possible so
that's fantastic on the other hand I'm
also seeing some states where the cases
are exploding Texas is an example where
10 days ago they had about 4 to 600 new
cases today now Texas has 8 to 12
hundred new cases a day so I have no
special insight I'm just looking at the
data and listening to health experts it
seems there are states that aren't yet
ready well a lot of those numbers when
it comes to more people getting it and
more people being asymptomatic is
actually good news if you have a higher
mortality rate we've actually broken the
curve especially in places where I'm
from
York I have family out there it seems to
be kind of breaking the fever as it were
it's not as bad as it once was
well I think what's important to look at
though is a lot of these states have
very low testing rates so let me I'll
give you one example and see if this
resonates with you in Massachusetts we
test at about three and a half times the
rate of Texas and the we used to always
have more new cases in Massachusetts
than in Texas that's reversed and for a
couple of days in the last week Texas
had more new cases than Massachusetts
despite only testing at about 30 percent
of the level of Massachusetts so that's
one thing I would certainly look at the
other is the deaths are not based on
testing so when you look at the actual
deaths those are also spiking in Texas
so I think you know your point is
well-taken but when you see death
spiking as well that's not about testing
rates what we're seeing right now I
think is a very big rise in
authoritarianism selves the Dallas woman
I described
she was actually told on video and this
is all over Fox this is one of the
biggest news stories and the United
States I'm not sure how you haven't seen
it but when it comes to the judge he was
a leftist judge that tweeted with her
you will apologize and bend the knee
unless I will take you to jail if you
don't and she didn't which I'm happy for
her but that's the type of power
grabbing we're seeing in the United
States right now and it's absolutely
unacceptable and it goes against
people's rights I would sure you're
great you would agree as a liberal you
know either classical liberal otherwise
it's going against their constitutional
rights and a huge scale what what's wait
hold on what goes against whose
constitutional right and which right
being able to feed their families people
being able to feed their families based
off of fear that mass backed by credible
numbers has not backed by facts we're
taking stuff on the cdc where one minute
they're saying that uh who by the way is
thirty percent funded by china wait a
second okay to where that it's not okay
to wear a mask
Tim you have to wear a mask we want to
wear it in the high
that's my piece here Tim we gotta go I
want to really understand what you're
saying
so which constitutional right is
violated by a stay at home public health
of guide line illegal search and seizure
on the 20 of them you got to stop them
with who what what search and seizure
happens when people are told you should
stay home and wear a mask in public
what's the search and see okay someone's
someone's at a park they get arrested by
the police like the woman in Idaho then
they search your vehicle is that illegal
you're all over the place to him we're
not talking about how my question was so
they search your car after in their
property and take her kid that wasn't
right what about a stay at home order
isn't it is an anti constitutional
illegal search and seizure okay so when
you don't stay at home and go to a place
like a public park where your tax
dollars pay for and then they arrest you
there because you're not so it's the
park oh they're windows
hold on is the park oh because Park
Rangers have authority right is the park
open or closed because if it's closed
you're trespassing right not federally
all right Tim all right my friend Tim's
all over the place he we can't stay at
first it was about a woman in Texas then
it's about Constitution then it's about
search and seizure then it's about it's
a closed Idaho park but then he says
it's it's not federal but you said it
was Idaho Tim's all over the place let's
go next to our caller from the seven one
six area code who's calling today from
seven one six hey who's this Xavier
what's up all right so I can't support
Joe Biden I'm sorry but his record on
segregation crime the crime bill and his
allegations with Tara Reid I can't
support bite him but I will say this I
do would you agree that it is the most
important thing that we do is to flip
this on it because if you think of
if Donald Trump gets reelected and you
have a Republican Senate that's gonna be
a disaster you're gonna get more
terrible policies pass if you have a Joe
Biden presidency but you have a
Republican Senate
I fear that that's going to enable bite
into a group to work with Republicans
more to do that to do like horrible
things maybe like touch Social Security
Medicaid because he said he is willing
to put that on the table right but I do
think if you so let me let me let's back
up so okay hold on so in the 90s Joe
Biden said he would not rule and so I
don't even care about that like this is
old stuff but I think it's important for
people to understand when you say Joe
Biden is considering cutting Social
Security and Medicare Joe Biden during
it was either an interviewer or debate
in the 90s said he wouldn't a priori
take off the table cuts to Social
Security and Medicare Joe Biden didn't
propose any such cuts and that was
almost 30 years ago and he's not talking
about that now so like we can we can
think whatever we think about Joe Biden
but you understand that I can't I can't
let you come in and say Joe Biden is
thinking about cutting Social Security
and Medicare when what happened was in
the 90s he said he wouldn't a priori
take it off the table
but he's not advocated for it and he
certainly isn't running on that now you
know that right we are not running on
that now but you see my pass right in
the 90s when he was asked in a situation
he said I wouldn't blindly take it off
the table now I disagree with that
position I I would say we're not cutting
it he didn't say it in the 90s but that
has nothing to do with what he's running
on now I don't want people to hear that
and think the wrong thing so here's my
perspective I don't think there's any
sense in me saying it's more important
that Biden beat Trump or it's more
important that Democrats take the Senate
these are separate elections and they
will very much go together so for
example in a state like Montana Biden is
he's losing but he's polling way better
than Democrats have done in the past and
the
incumbent Republican senator in Montana
is losing right now to Steve Bullock so
there's not really this one or the other
thing and they're going to be decided
separately although they've seemed to
move in parallel if Biden does really
well it's more likely that a bunch of
Republican senators would lose so I
don't think it's the right approach to
say it's more important to take the
Senate it's actually these things are
linked and you can vote you get a vote
for the Senate and you get a vote for
president and we can do both okay all
right Savior thank you very much
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to our caller from the eight zero one
area code
who's calling today from eight zero one
welcome hey David thanks for having me
I just want to ask you what extent
should someone tolerate the religion or
the religious practices of their parents
and how should you approach a
conversation with your parents if you
feel like there are certain Minds being
crossed okay so I'm having a little bit
of trouble understanding exactly what
you're saying the first part was to what
extent should you respect the religious
views of your parents or tolerate I
think was the word you used yep tolerate
well III would want to know what you
mean if or if you're asking do you need
to be the same religion as your parents
or have the same views I think the
answer is clearly no if you're talking
about do you should you be respectful of
your parents views in order to maintain
a friendly relationship then that's sort
of up to you and what your priorities
are right yeah no that makes sense so
what was the other part of a question
yeah so if there are certain practices
that your parents engage in whether it's
prayer or whether it's like imposing
certain beliefs
yeah in this case it's speaking
specifically like Christianity how
should you approach the conversation
with them that their beliefs and their
practices sort of make you uncomfortable
and make you uneasy what would be the
point what would be your goal in the
conversation let's start there yeah I
guess just to be on the same page with
them but I want them
do you want them to stop the prayer and
so in some settings right so I'll give
you an example
my staff and I had a get-together with a
bunch of different people from my family
and their family and at a certain point
my parents decided they were going to
pray and invite everyone to do like a
group prayer and I sort of asked him not
to engage in that but they sort of did
it anyway and it just seemed like any
conversation I had with them about
whether or not that prayer was gonna
happen
wasn't conducted right and I think I've
had just been approaching it the wrong
way but I wanted to get your advice I
mean listen II know I I've actually I
know friends who have experienced that
situation I have some friends who the
parents so it's a couple the parents of
one of the people are completely
non-religious the parents of the other
person in the couple are very religious
and often want when everybody gets
together they want to do 30 minutes of
Bible study and stuff like that the way
that it was handled there and I can't
think of any other way to do it quite
frankly is the the child of the
religious parents pulled them aside and
said listen my spouse's family is not
religious we want to have a nice time
people get uncomfortable when you want
to do 30 minutes of Bible study and it
would be better for everybody if we skip
that and they they did take offense but
they accepted it and there's no more
Bible study when everybody gets together
but the thing is it that that's how one
set of people reacted you know your
parents may react in a different way so
I don't know that there's one right
answer here katja I don't envy the
position that you're in yeah alright
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you let's take a quick break if you
were holding
don't hang up because we are gonna go
right back to the phones it's gonna feel
like it's mere seconds stay with you
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show let's get right back
to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's
go to our caller from the 7 1 8 area
code caller from 7 1 8 what's your name
where you calling from
hey JD what's up the capacity of the
u.s. in your opinion to provide the
opportunities for a healthy safe and
prosperous life in the years ahead
substantially diminished co-stars cop to
I asked is a well-traveled person and a
first-generation American and a person
of color who works remotely in IT
currently and I'm prepared to i'ma grade
out of America after travel restrictions
are lifted
separately speaking to relatives who
work in health care in New York and the
DC areas yeah I figured out the worst of
the sauce cough - pandemic here in the
US is ahead of us not behind us
hopefully you can see some of my fears
and frustrations but thank you for
everything you do David well listen I
mean here's the deal JD the the pandemic
itself at some point is going to pass
and there's going to be irreparable
health harm that is done - what what
could be hundreds of thousands of people
that die we don't really know what the
death toll will be but it seems like you
know within a month it could be over a
hundred thousand and then who knows how
high it's going to go in the u.s.
eventually we're going to get past it
and the economy will start to recover
but what we've learned from this is that
even an economy that looks pretty solid
and I talked about this on yesterday's
program is pretty fragile right like
it's pretty damn fragile I mean the
stock market was near record highs
unemployment near
record lows we had consumer confidence
was relatively high inflation under
control etc etc and in eight weeks we've
lost twenty-one percent of the workforce
21 percent of the workforce has lost
their jobs there are people without
health insurance there are people who
are in Food lines so I don't know that
the pandemic will actually change the
reality of this fragile economy but the
pandemic has exposed how fragile even a
seemingly good economy can be and that
is something that I'm guessing people
are going to remember the rest of their
lives
thank you David alright appreciate the
call thank you so much let's go next to
our caller from the 757 area code
who's calling today from 757 hello yeah
that's you
hey David this is a air from Virginia
Aaron okay cool Aaron let me just
mention so we're having this issue with
the phone system where when people talk
loud it actually creates a paper
crunching noise and I can't control that
on my end so maybe just put the phone
like a couple inches further from your
face and then I think you'll come in
beautifully that is so much better thank
you all right I'm doing this article on
Washington Post about Trump installing
this Republican donor to the Postmaster
General position yes and I really I just
have two questions one is there any
argument that Trump has that maybe
Amazon isn't paying enough for the
delivery and I coorporate the paying
enough delivery there is even an
argument there there's no argument that
so let me address that Amazon makes
deals with multiple carriers so I'm not
an expert on shipping and logistics but
from what I understand Amazon I believe
Amazon in the u.s. only uses UPS I don't
think they do FedEx although I may be
wrong but my understanding is that in
the u.s. Amazon cuts a deal with UPS
where they are not literally paying for
every package the way you or I might if
we send a few packages a month my
understanding is that it's a combination
of fixed fee deals plus some
their amounts so Amazon and other large
shippers have always struck deals with
shippers where if you only look at the
per package price it might seem like
it's a loss but you need to look at the
value of the total contract so my point
is I don't know that what Trump is
saying tells us the whole picture but I
would need to investigate it more okay
and effect having this Republican
appointee the position to control people
voting by mail that out this 2010
election yeah
seems pretty scary about Trump so Trump
fires inspectors general who are going
to look into things that he doesn't want
looked into Trump bullies departments
into getting rid of people that are
opposed to what Donald Trump wants to do
so unfortunately this is a situation
we're between a rock and a hard place
because the only solution is to remove
Trump in November and yet Donald Trump
is taking steps like appointing a
friendly Postmaster General who may be
able to assist in not having
vote-by-mail work so one way would be
it's gonna be up to States to decide
about vote by mail you could have a
state say hey we're gonna do vote by
mail and then the Postmaster General can
generate a paper which says hey you know
what
the post office would not be able to
properly handle all of Florida voting by
mail and they can create all of this
fear uncertainty and doubt to put it in
question whether we're gonna do it so
unfortunately our only solution is to
remove Trump and Trump is actually
putting people in power who may hamper
our ability to do that I don't have an
answer it's dystopian and nightmarish
and you're right to point it out it even
seems like he could just you know go had
them blown straight like they shut it
down I don't know what the logistics of
that would be but I would I wouldn't put
anything past Trump to at least attempt
at this point in time and he knows
vote-by-mail would be terrible for him
and he's going to try to prevent it from
happening at least in swing states where
where it could flip the results Wow
pretty good
all right appreciate the call thank you
so much let me go next to Mike from
Boston Mike from Boston we haven't heard
from for for a little while I guess
what's going on with you Mike
hi David thanks for taking my call
pleasure hum you know I just want to
respond to this and kind of get your
view on it a couple callers ago I'm
really getting sick of these delusional
people out there and some of the people
on other progressive podcasts and blogs
people you know like crystal ball on on
rising and I know he's your friend
calculon's beyond secular talk who are
just so anti Joe Biden and they seem to
be out for blood for him and I really
can't understand why if this crisis
right now that we are going through it
does not signal to people that chump
must be removed at all costs
right you are not only irresponsible
you're a borderline selfish just and not
caring about the lives that are being
lost so let's take that i babies let me
let's take that piece by piece Mike so
first of all I have no idea what Krystle
and Kyle have been saying a big again I
just I just don't watch shows I work on
my show you know 12 hours a day and then
I relax with some stuff that's not
political content but so let's let's go
through it in pieces first of all remove
Trump at all costs not if you're going
to replace him with something worse
right so like I've made the calculation
that Biden is better than Trump that's
why I am going to vote for Joe Biden to
replace Trump if you give me an option
that's worse than Trump then I say keep
Trump because I want to do harm
reduction that part probably we agree on
right well yeah I mean but the only real
I agree at this point in the review
options it's Joe Biden or it's Donald
Trump now right why would crystal I'm
taking your word that crystal and Kyle
are very much anti Trump as you point
out my guess is if you ask them why they
would say that it's because maybe they
don't see Biden is better than Trump or
they see by
being elected as a path to something
that doesn't fix the problem in the
longer term my you'd have to ask them
right I mean you're asking me about
stuff I haven't seen my guess is if you
ask them they they would have a
different perspective about and they
would be able to articulate why they are
as anti by didn't as you described them
to be I've made my view clear which is
when I look at history I don't see
acceleration Asteria aving worked and
acceleration is perspectives as having
worked I see we have succeeded through
getting people in power who will make
responsible choices to the Supreme Court
which will then uphold the improvements
that are made by the people that we
elect that that's what I've seen in the
Progressive Era the New Deal era and the
civil rights era so that's how I have
established my framework and I think
what you're pointing to is somebody who
has a different framework I would say so
yes I mean but I just don't get the
point I mean I I don't think I look at
that I look at the landscape in the
country
the way that this crisis is being
handled the way that the last three and
a half years have gone and I don't I
don't think this country can handle
another four years of Donald Trump I
agree with you I'm not happen to agree
with you I mean listen my so everybody
has to figure out what works for them as
I said before somebody doesn't want to
vote Biden because they actually believe
the country is better off with Biden
losing and Trump getting four more years
then they shouldn't vote Biden right but
I just I want everybody to be clear and
there's a there's a contingent that I'm
seeing not Kyle and crystal but stuff
like I'll look at my subreddit each day
and I'll look at my Twitter mentions
each day where there are people who are
doing an anti by Dan thing but they're
not actually saying they think Trump is
better so then it's like well what are
you just posturing or are you trying to
get a certain reaction are you trying to
get Joe to come beg for your vote or
whatnot like I don't need any of that
stuff I'm plenty busy I was like byte
whatever I'm going for Biden they're mad
that they didn't get their diet
as Bernie Sanders and I was at Bernie
Sanders guy okay and I understand a
disappointment yeah but you know
sometimes when there's no great choice
and there's no right answer you do what
you gotta do and take the best option
available to use on Drive that's my
perspective and you know what I think is
important to do is I don't see any
benefit in going around and attacking
the motives of Christal and Kyle like
again I'm going by what you're telling
me but if they've come to the conclusion
that they're never voting Biden and I'm
not saying that that's what they're I
don't know if that's what they're doing
but if they did my instinct is to assume
again because I know them to some degree
I I assume that they've come to that
conclusion through some different
framework than I have
rather than they don't care about death
like you said I mean clearly they both
care about death I know them well enough
to know they care about people dying I'm
guessing they're working with a
different framework right I guess my
point is is that I guess what I'm trying
to say that that if in my in my opinion
in my view if you really care about the
well-being of this country you know and
you were a Bernie Sanders supporter or
an Elizabeth Warren supporter and you
know you're looking at this election and
you're just gonna say well you know what
if I couldn't just get my guy and if we
can't have it all or nothing right now
right I don't really care what happens
to the country I'm gonna vote third
party or not vote at all or and do
whatever I think you're I think you're
extremely off-base and extremely selfish
and not really caring about a lot of the
suffering that's going on with some of
these people right now
yes I'm like it's not your frustration
is that there are people who are coming
to different conclusions than you and
you're frustrated by that because for
you the the conclusion you've come to is
so obvious right I mean look I was gonna
vote for whoever the Democratic nominee
was that's just how I went into this
whole you know election cycle which
we're going because I've seen what
happens when you make your responsible
choices and I just think they're being
irresponsible Thanks all right Mike from
Boston great to hear from you let's see
if we can check in with our caller from
the 6-1-6 area code who is calling today
for
six one six I think that's me yes it is
in here yeah hi David
thanks for choosing the number this is
Justin from Michigan Hey Joe how the
Westside this is a bit more of a
technical question here but just to jump
right in
I don't recall you commenting on the
israeli-palestinian deal of the century
quote-unquote opposed by Trump which was
largely drafted by Jared Kushner so if
you've seen this oppose map the
potential Palestinian state looks like
scattered islands more or less within
the Negev desert and as you probably
heard gansan Netanyahu just recently
signed an agreement to essentially annex
laws of the West Bank seeming in tandem
with this plan you know just to complete
it for the 2020 election and just sort
of report they suspected it here but it
also to sort of sweep it under the rug
during the corona virus pandemic so my
question is what do you think of the
plan is it in any way feasible and isn't
it sort of a slap in the face to
Palestinian aspirations of a statehood
along the 1967 borders
I know it's loaded but hey here's some
foreign policy for you so is this by
this one you say that this is the deal
from about a year ago right that's right
yeah yeah so I did I did comment on it
at the time and did one or two pretty
detailed clips about it I don't have the
map in front of me but certainly I've
spoken before about the importance of
you know having a contiguous Palestinian
state my you know without having all of
the details refreshed right in front of
me I wouldn't be able to say anything
more than what I said a year ago or
whenever when when I covered it although
what I will restate is I simply do not
believe that the arbiters to a long
lasting deal in the israeli-palestinian
conflict are going to be Benjamin
Netanyahu nor any deal in which Hamas is
involved that I've been saying that for
years
I maintain that that is the case that
that will not be the case that that
won't work and beyond that you know Mike
I haven't looked at the deal for a year
and you know I would check out my prior
commentary
hmm kena follow that up quickly sir so
with so would you then argue that any
plan should begin with the Palestinian
Authority which would then be widely
embraced by the Palestinian people in
Gaza which would then you know in turn I
don't know where they keep the a domino
effect with Hamas leadership I eat well
what I would love to see first would be
Hamas removed from power period before
we have to have this domino effect and
and again that the Hamas has a
stranglehold in Gaza and I don't know
that I see that happening anytime soon
either mm-hmm right absolutely both hey
I'll definitely check out those clips
thank you so much for your response and
yeah I'll be calling it at some point
with with with perhaps a few different
questions for you about foreign policy
but thank you so much thank you so much
I appreciate the phone call great to
hear from you I as always apologize to
everybody I was not able to get to but
we will take calls again we'll go to a
quick break and be back with your
questions after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
all right let's get right into audience
questions for the week I understand what
is on people's minds and that explains
why these are the questions I've gotten
first one is hey David what is the
longest that the United States can
realistically stay shut down because of
coronavirus so I'm gonna answer the
question as asked but please understand
that we never really shut down to the
degree that Europe did and when you look
at you know 4.8% GDP decline in q1
that's that's a lot that's crazy but
that's an economy that's mostly still
open now okay the shutdowns didn't start
until March if we have a 20% decline in
q2 April May June that is crazy that's a
crazy but consider that that still means
80% of the economy is still up and
running so compared to Europe the United
States restrictions have been really
light the stay home orders have been put
in place in a number of states essential
stores are still open for the most part
you know all grocery stores hardware
stores in Massachusetts restaurants
remained open for take-out people could
go around not wearing masks outdoors and
even indoors for a long time you could
go wherever you want parks were open
some places have had to close parks
because of people gathering a lot of
beaches remained open as long as people
weren't on top of each other in Italy
just this week people started to be
allowed to go more than 200 meters from
their house or fight I think in Spain it
was 500 meters we never had that in the
United States even in the strictest
situations wherever I don't know if we
would consider Michigan to have been the
strictest or whatnot but we were never
really fully shut down and a lot of what
we saw in the u.s. is really a city
versus suburban suburb rural distinction
because I've been in Boston restaurants
remained open for take-out but the
streets are quite empty there's like
very little traffic going places so
certainly the more urban areas of the
city seem noticeably empty but a lot of
the basics stayed open the entire time
supper
may not even have been as dramatically
different I it's hard for me to say for
sure so the answers in terms of how much
longer can we stay quote shutdown it's
very clear that there is not a lot of
political appetite even in the more
liberal states to stay shut even a
single day longer than public health
officials say that we should so I think
we're increasingly going to start seeing
two tiers we are going to start to see
places that had early hot spots and took
it very seriously New York and
Massachusetts in California are the ones
I'm most familiar with that in the next
two weeks to four weeks two to three
weeks are going to be able to start
opening some things with caution
still with masks indoors outdoors when
you can't social distance but there will
be some opening up more than likely
manufacturing hopefully can start to
come back with people wearing masks and
distancing in factories etc the
governor's will sort of figure it out
the problem is that we are starting to
see rapidly rising cases in places like
Florida Georgia Texas and there are
others although I don't have the numbers
readily sort of in my mind and on a
percentage basis they are seeing faster
and faster increases in cases they're
not going to be able to open up or if
they do it is going to be significantly
tragic significantly tragic so you have
some states starting to say we're going
to start running out of unemployment
insurance money that's going to be
pressure especially for Republican
governors who are very concerned with
debt in this abstract sense to try to
open up the saddest part about all of it
and ultimately these are decisions that
governor's will have to make and the
answer as many of them are going to
start opening some things in the next
two to three weeks sadly if on March 5th
when we had over 200 cases Trump had
said from the federal government I need
all 50 governors to do a
shelter-in-place stay at home order we
had done that on March 5th we would be
in really good shape right now that's
what we're seeing in other countries
South Korea took care of things despite
having their first case at the same time
we did and that is that is the really
lost opportunity that there's no way to
go back
do at this point in time hey David both
Biden and Trump are older and have
political problems that might prevent
them from making it to November who are
the likely Biden and Trump replacements
if they don't make it to election day so
we'll deal with Biden first and then
talk about Donald Trump it's a little
bit of a weird question but I'll answer
it if you don't believe Joe Biden is
going to make it to November I presume
you mean because of his age because I
don't really know of what else is going
to knock Joe Biden out I know that there
are people saying he should resign
because he's been accused of sexual
assault that's not really the way things
work in the United States right
Republican Democrat for better or for
worse in particular Joe Biden's winning
every national poll an even competitive
in a bunch of red states that Trump won
easily you don't usually bow out when
you're winning every poll so people who
are you know using hashtags about drop
out Biden and this sort of stuff for me
Biden is on the ballot in November
unless he's dead or in a coma by that
point in time now maybe there are people
again who are thinking that the Tara
Reid thing is going to make Joe Biden
step back I just think it's it's
unrealistic
so if Joe Biden doesn't make it to
November because he dies again I think
that's really the only way that it
happens it would seem natural that it
would be Bernie Sanders who would
replace Joe Biden in the sense that
Bernie Sanders had the second most
delegates during the primary before
dropping out I think what would
complicate it is if Biden chooses a
running mate soon you would have a
debate if Biden chooses a running mate
and then for whatever reason cannot
continue the campaign I think you would
have a fight between whether the running
mate replaces Biden or whether Bernie
Sanders replaces Biden I think it would
be horribly toxic and divisive and could
probably end up hurt a helping Donald
Trump I hope it doesn't happen all right
that's on the Joe Biden south side on
the Trump side again I assume people are
talking mostly because of age Trump's
not going to be removed by impeachment
he's not going to be removed by the 25th
amendment
not gonna be arrested or anything like
that so maybe people think Trump is in a
70s and in poor health so maybe that's
what they're looking at I think
Republicans go right to Mike Pence I
don't think there's any question
whatsoever I don't think there's even
much to debate I know that the idea has
been floated of maybe Trump would
replace pence for his 2020 run obviously
that ship has sailed the Trump pence
2020 signs are everywhere Mike Pence has
been made sort of a figure and a
prominent figure in the coronavirus task
force the spice despite being a complete
clown Trump has made him a prominent
figure in the briefings etc so I think
it obviously goes right to pence don't
see it going any other way
if you disagree on either if you
disagree on what happens if Biden
doesn't make it to November or if Trump
doesn't make it to November let me know
hey David
when will you start going to restaurants
the gym the movies traveling and doing
all of your normal life after
coronavirus I don't know I've been
thinking about this a lot talking to
friends and family and I'm planning to
get an antibody test next week or the
week after and it's conceivable that my
behavior may be different if it turns
out that I already had the virus I think
that that might affect my behavior to
some degree but I'm not just thinking
about myself I'm thinking about do I
want to be seeing my parents when this
starts dying down because if so I
probably need to do the responsible
thing and not go to some of these places
particularly if I don't have the
antibodies if I want to be around my
parents so I think for me the gym seems
pretty far off that seems like a
cesspool of germs and contagion I never
go to the movies as it is the last movie
I saw was not the latest Star Wars but
the previous one is the last time I went
to the movies I think that was three or
four years ago here in Boston so I think
I'm fine without going to the movies I
don't really care about the movies for
me the big things really are seeing
friends particularly at beer gardens or
going to restaurants going to cafes etc
I'm feeling like if they
are going to start opening some of those
up with reduced capacity my favorite
cafe said we're gonna operate at 20%
capacity and the employees will wear
masks and you know it's kind of hard to
have a mask on when when you're eating
or drinking but I would probably go and
sit with my laptop if the numbers keep
declining in Massachusetts the way they
have been if in three weeks those places
start to open I'd probably go and sit
with my laptop for two hours have a
coffee then come home wash my hands and
I think I would be comfortable with that
Travel is a real question mark I don't
know I had a bunch of trips canceled
including I was supposed to be in LA on
the Joe Rogan program last week and I
had vacations planned I don't know when
that's going to resume but I will
probably just look at you know when when
we travels down air travels down 95% my
sense is what I'm not gonna be the first
person to get back on a plane when I see
the numbers recovering particularly
evaluating the case cases in
Massachusetts and where I would be
flying to I'll kind of make that call
when it comes to it I would love to be
able to go somewhere in August at this
point I don't know if we'll still be in
wave one or maybe already in wave two or
maybe things would be okay to travel I
don't know but I'm not making any any
sort of bigger decisions about that
right now
curious to hear where your mind is I
know I have I have friends who have been
traveling throughout and I have friends
who are saying they're not traveling
until 2022 or going to restaurants
period for any time in the foreseeable
future I guess I'm kind of in the middle
and I'm gonna make decisions on a
case-by-case basis right now I'm looking
to May 18 to see how much do cases
hopefully keep declining in
Massachusetts and will our governor
Charlie Baker open anything up on that
date let me know your thoughts we've got
a fantastic bonus show for you today get
instant access to the bonus show two
ways these are quick you go to join
pakman.com and just sign up the coupon
code 2020 now saves you 66% if you want
it sign up in under a minute get the
bonus show
or become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show also takes under a
minute
gets you instant access to the bonus
show we'll see you then or on Monday
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]